well I'm sure this must have happened
when you decided to stop drinking you
must have thought this isn't good I'm
not gonna be funny anymore I thought
that I liked I thought there was gonna
be ramifications yeah okay and so what
were they what what did you what did you
foresee happening I thought I wouldn't
be funny I thought that people wouldn't
like me I thought that I wouldn't be
able to meet girls if I wasn't drinking
or or you know or having drugs or right
so that was what you were afraid of
giving up if you stopped drinking
right what were you afraid of happening
if you kept drinking I was afraid of not
achieving my dreams I was right rate of
you know ending up a drug addict yeah
it's sort of dying in my sleep something
you know dying under the inflow case so
they're so they're yeah it's not like
that doesn't happen to comedians right
on the law exactly well it's not an
occupational hazard because you're up
late at night in your own bars all day
it is it is because it is because you're
up late at night and yet cross Marley
right here right right everyone it
happened to all sorts of comedians and
rock musicians usually happens at about
27 you know weirdly enough so okay so
you were afraid you were afraid you're
gonna die or you're afraid you're gonna
become addicted so so let's say what
what of life what would have life like
being like you for you if you were
addicted so you don't have a career
anymore no right so you given all that
up and failed so that's fun so that's
gonna drive you even more time towards
drugs yeah it would've been all my dream
it would have been miserable right away
then hell exactly is that so why quit
drinking so I don't end up in hell hey
there's a reason there's a reason to
stop and then if you make that hell real
it's like here's all the details of my
personal hell yes let's avoid that right
so then you have something to run the
hell away from right so you have some
more towards and it's something run away
from and I'll say this too as you for if
there's any young man or women out there
we were listening to Jordan feeling like
well I still I don't know if you know if
I start doing something different like
my friends are gonna act this hurt yeah
they are they are yeah you're also
you're gonna start creating
conversations you're gonna become the
entry because you're gonna be bringing
something new to the table you're also
gonna find out who your friends are yeah
because if you're starting to put your
life together and you have friends that
object those are not friends those are
just people you know they're not friends
because a free
and is someone this is one of the
hallmarks of a friend here's two
hallmarks hmm a friend is someone you
can tell bad news to and they won't tell
you why you're an idiot and they won't
interfere with your sulfurous listened
they'll just listen and maybe they'll
suffer along with you okay so you can
tell bad news to them and they won't
tell you some worst thing that happened
to them they'll listen now suffer along
with you but a friend is also someone
you can tell good news to and the friend
will say Wow
in this vale of tears something good
happen to you great man wonderful it's
rare it's unlikely good for you
I hope ten more things like that happen
and they're not envious and they're not
jealous and they're not one and up on
you and if you're trying to get your
life together it's actually if you're
trying to get your life together and
your friends get in the way that's
actually real useful for you because
you've now identified who your friends
aren't mm-hmm and you might think well I
can't give them up it's like oh yes you
can and not only can you you should and
it would be better for them because if
they're aiming down and they want you
going down with them there's nothing
good about what's happening to them and
there's certainly nothing good about
that for you you know they're not gonna
and then they're gonna learn wow if I
I'm gonna lose friends if I continue in
these directions yeah exactly exactly is
it hard for why is it hard for people to
let go of what's so familiar with to
them even if it's bad
well because it's complicated you know
and the thing that's a really good
question you discount the risk of
familiarity that they're familiar with
so like let's say because people are in
relationships people are in
relationships with the drugs and alcohol
people in relationships with humans
people are in relationships with jobs
people in relationships with their own
selves and they deliver they're living a
lie every single day but it's it's
familiarity yeah well you say I have a
job I hate it's like well yeah but I'm
not dying from it it's like not as bad
as it can be so you kind of you got it
that you've factored in the risks
already they get invisible you think
well I can't jump out of this job
because what about all the risk it's
like yeah no kidding you got to make a
you've got to get your resume in order
you got to send it out you got to send
50 the damn things out before anybody
will call you back then you have to go
get interviewed and maybe you're not any
good at that you have to come up with a
story while you're a good employee
and maybe and maybe you're not yet so
you have to figure out how to do that
it's like what about all these risks if
I go look for a new job it's like yeah
absolutely man those are risks and
they're harsh and no wonder you're
avoiding them what about the risks for
you to stay with this job you absolutely
hate well let's think that through okay
so I have this dead-end job I hate it
I'm getting better where am I gonna be
in five years I know where because I've
watched this with people you're gonna be
you're gonna be just like you are now
except a lot more of what's good about
you is going to be gone and a lot more
of what's terrible is going to be
amplified and you're gonna be like in
five years you're gonna be ten years
older instead of three years older Yeah
right and because it kills your spirits
oh man yeah so it's like you think oh my
god there's a terrible risk in pursuing
this new job it's like yeah there is a
terrible risk there's a terrible risk
and you stand with your job right now
and so one of the things that's really
really freeing to understand is that
you're screwed no matter what you do
there's no secure path forward give it
up it's risk everywhere oh my god that's
terrible it's like yes except for two
things you can pick your risk that's the
first thing so you get to pick your
poison something and second you're a lot
tougher than you think so even though
there's risk everywhere if you confront
it forthrightly what you'll find is that
you can actually handle the risk and
that's the security that's beautiful and
there's so much growth to be had right
there when you realize how much like
there were times I was like man I could
never be a sober person because I'm
afraid of you know I can't communicate
with women or I'm afraid to you know
stand around in a circle with tough guys
without having like a beer in my hand
you know we're like all these little
crutches you know I can't and then I
remember when I got like 90 days sober I
was just like holy [ __ ] man like it was
like the first time I'd ever done
something like for myself you know yeah
and it just man it felt it felt
unprecedented yeah yeah what was it like
I'd gone to the moon how old were you
when you started drinking uh I'm
probably like 17 or 16 you know kind of
regular yeah it was pretty basic and I
never did a bunch of it you know but my
biggest thing was just emotional
sobriety like I was so drunk on my own
insecurities and low self alcohol
alcohol really is a good
for coping with anxiety that's when
people use it so does too if you if you
really like alcohol it does it does two
things to you it makes you more
extroverted and enthusiastic well you're
on the ascending limb of the
blood-alcohol curve which is why you
have to keep drinking once you start
because if you plateau that goes away so
you go to keep drinking okay so that's
one thing it makes you more enthusiastic
and and more full of positive emotion
and the second thing it does is reduce
anxiety yeah so if you are a bit more
socially anxious and you also have that
positive response to alcohol which
everyone doesn't have by the way then
it's a great drug but the problem is
it's well it's a great drug for the
moment right right there's there's
consequences yeah this doesn't it's not
great well I did also alcohol is an
interesting drug because it it it
actually doesn't make people stupid this
is being tested like alcohol people who
are drunk will take far more risk and
you might say well that's because
they're too stupid to understand the
risk it's like no they're not if you ask
them about the risk when they're drunk
they can outline it perfectly what it
stops them from doing is caring about
the risk it's actually and that's part
of the anti-anxiety components like yeah
the risk is that's why you can drive
around drunk at high speed in a car
which is a really stupid thing to do
yeah we used to do that in the back
roads of northern Alberta it's fun yeah
you know but but people died all the
time doing it especially in the winter
it's like wow this is great it's great
until your head's gone through the
windshield you know like so many things
yeah it's like jumping off a cliff it's
I'm flying that's true until the last
1/10 of a second like then you're not
flying man yeah yeah
so so alcohol alcohol has exactly that
effect it is a great aunt anti-anxiety
drug but it does stop you and he said it
stopped you from learning the skills
that you need in a social circumstance
to be able to cope with that so then it
actually stops you from dealing with the
anxiety you don't have to learn how to
overcome it that's not good yeah so yeah
yeah you're not really learning you're
kind of just staying in the you're just
you're baiting the egg you're you're
kind of meeting the anxiety with a
little bit of light medication but
you're never getting through whatever
the anxiety was yeah you don't look you
don't have to learn the skills well you
said you like to stand there with a beer
in your hand we'll give you something to
do you didn't know what else to do then
you didn't have to learn I had the same
issue like I started drinking when I was
13
probably yeah and and that's late in
Canada yeah that's right I was way
behind my neighbors they were slogging
it back when they were four oh I've been
in Edmonton and I've seen people I mean
it's just people love to drink updates
it's a fun culture right it's a cordial
thing on the farther north you go the
more the drinking becomes necessary in
the winter you know so and there's not
that much to do in those isolated small
town yeah I drink I drink my own blood
party and when I used to go back to the
little town I was from when I was an
adult even if I hadn't never really had
anything to drink for years it was like
well what are we gonna do
well let's go to the bar why well
because there actually isn't anything
else to do so you know and so you end up
there but but but the alcohol is it's
it's a hell of a drug do you think watch
it do you think it's going to start get
out to get outdated I start to think
that alcohol is almost a drug of the
past slowly like I could see us like
with psychedelics and stuff like that
becoming a little bit more in like the
common sphere of conversation well be
interesting to see that we just
legalized marijuana in Canada yeah yeah
like it's not it's not completely legal
yet but the bill was passed so Canada is
doing this countrywide experiment and I
know there is some data showing that in
counties in the US where marijuana has
been legalized the overuse of opiates
for pain has decreased substantially the
crime rates have gone down interesting
well story PBS don't pot it's hard to
pick somebody's pocket yeah break it to
a building I don't think so it's not
gonna get it together you might not for
a long time yeah you might knock at the
front door you gotta break in and you're
not gonna make it you might that's right
you're not gonna go what are you gonna
go on the Le and have a fight no you
know what real slow fight while you're
watching your hands like yeah there's
like chess with your hands exactly
that's not gonna happen so yeah who
knows like I mean if we had to make a
bad drug legal the worst choice was
alcohol yeah definitely the case you
know what I'm saying that as somewhat of
a fan of El Cajon
no me too yeah I like it it's but if
it's a bad drug and is it also starting
to become archaic as we get into drugs
that are you know like uh you know
people are using psychedelics more where
people are a little bit curious about
drugs that make you think
instead of instead of drugs that make
you not think right yeah right yeah yeah
cuz alcohols kind of but an escape into
well it's not full unconsciousness
although it certainly can be yeah but
yeah an alcohol also makes people
aggressive it's the only drug we know
that actually makes people aggressive so
and so so you see a massive effect on
crime rates because half the people who
murder someone are drunk oh yeah and
half the people who are murdered are
drunk and you know and you're most
likely to be murdered by a family member
so I'd be joking with my audiences is
like well if you really want to get
killed the best thing to do is go drink
with a family which is actually
statistically true which is terribly
terribly cold it's like yeah go get
drunk in your family if you want to die
thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz this is alarming